we'll see if j half can have a better
outing
here in the ball game tonight last time
out nine earned runs the sox put on him
hopefully it starts early with anderson
who
for whatever reason sees hap probably
better than anybody in baseball i can't
believe they're better numbers against
him
than tim anderson and a base hit this
one to left field though for the ball
game on two strikes
great way to start it off and tim trying
to psych up his teammates
here's madrigal there it goes
exactly there tim stops at second and
madrigal and anderson have back-to-back
singles to open the ball game
outside ball four they are loaded before
and
out jay needs to settle in here against
your mean mercedes
mercedes that's a fair ball down the
line
and start the carousel says tim anderson
he's home
madrigal follows and the sox have a
two-nothing lead
with nobody out in the first inning and
this is what happens when you just put
the bat on the ball make some contact he
slices it by snow at first base
andrew vaughan playing first base for
brayu tonight
still looking for the first out and
upstairs
foul tip and garber hung on vaughn's a
strikeout victim for the first out of
the inning
and that'll bring up yasmani grandal at
the very least yasmani wants to look for
something up in the zone
he wants to hit a fly ball again at the
very least
he did and he skies it to right for
garlic that should be an rbi monkata
tags from third
he's on his way home and grandahl does
exactly what he wanted at the very least
and gives the sox a three-nothing lead
dallas last time he faced jay
he got 13 runs he's got three early and
he probably figures and this his ninth
start if he can get
in the teens every time he'll pitch
three times a week
cutter inside good combo change up to
cutter against the right-handed garlic
and one gone josh donaldson
swings at the first offer he lifts into
center where billy
hamilton will make the catch so quickly
two up two down
now nelson cruz the pitch swing and a
miss
strike three like that yep two
strikeouts as he
sets him down one two three after an
inning
twins up bottom two down three nothing
one pitch one out
and here is garbage high fly right
center field
got some carry to it this ball's back
and it's off the wall
carver has the first hit and he'll glide
into second with a double good at bat
for mitch garber
driving one to the opposite field gap
and the twins have a run around down by
three
and now ref snyder in his third game as
a twin
that's a fair ball down the line out of
the reach of moncada
and garber around third and here he
comes home rep snyder to second base
with a double
back-to-back doubles it's a 3-1 game
[Music]
and rob rossner has made an immediate
impact in
the first game plus that he's played for
the twins got two
huge hits yesterday two outs in the
inning here's a rise
swinging a ground ball right to the
second baseman madrigal he'll
lob toss devaughn and the twins are on
the board
sox lead after two it's 3-1 now the
twins got one back on the second and now
in the third inning it'll be nick
madrigal one and two to madrigal that
falls level
to left field by madrigal and his first
career home run
madrigal bring him home for the first
time
he's got a major league home run
and the big smile crosses his face
for a 4-1 lead very fittingly
nikki two strikes has his first major
league home run
and that is big news in the sox dugout
all four moncada walks for the second
time
nobody out for your mean mercedes
with a great catch across the line and a
double play
i believe that'll be ruled a foul ball
but sano
inching off the bag holding the runner
then dope back across the bag
4-1 white sox anderson to second just
setting up nick madrigal the power man
madrigal shoots it to right down the
line
nick madrigal is swinging a volcanic
stick
and it's 5-1 drives in his second
run gives him 13 for the year that will
be it perhaps fourth inning the new
pitcher
is right-handed reliever derrick law
oncotta will bat from the left side
okada drills this ball right center
field with a wall keep it in the answer
is yes
but the sox will take the run thank you
johan monkatta
has a hit in seven straight and the
socks are pouring it out of the twin
cities
bottom four sox leads six to one polanco
fly out victim in the second there's a
one hopper to the third baseman mankata
backhanded play throw to first
he got him that's a great play john made
it look routine you know moncada will
make plays look like they're not that
tough kind of like louise robert again
in center field here's hasta deal
and he lines to mendic in right
and that'll do it for the twins in the
fourth
kykel's been great sox offense has been
great and the bases are loaded danny
mendick will bat
danny mendick in the air left center
field it goes to the wall
it's a grand slam danny mendick
takes it up and out and bring them all
home it's 10-1.
wow it's an assault on the twin cities
10-1 sox in the fifth
here's billy hamilton nobody out and
what a great payoff for hamilton
flying around first he'll fly around
second there'll be a play at third base
here's the throw
and it hits hamilton and then kicks and
he'll run to home plate
and there's a heck of a scoop by ostidio
to get him out
law backing up the play as he should but
he threw a one hopper to ostadio and
made a great play to get it out
hamilton will get credit for a triple
thrown out trying to score
four and a half complete here at target
field ref snyder is two for two
miguel 3-2 snow ground ball to third
picked up by moncotta he fires to
madrigal one
relay two that is a double play
a rise with two down line drive out
toward left center
and a diving catch billy hamilton he was
shaded that way but he had to leave his
feet
white sox making it happen tonight after
five
granddaughter walks again base is loaded
and here's garcia in a bat that falls
tagged to right field
on a line into the gap it goes more
to come molcata
and mercedes and it's a dozen tonight
for the sox
and they're definitely not saying burns
in minneapolis
on the ground that's going to get
another run home it's an rbi for danny
mendick who's driven in five
that's 13. and here is the exciting
billy hamilton
through the left side number 14 come on
down
bears end the season with the vikings
sox have two touchdowns and two extra
points
white sox had four more we go to the
bottom of the sixth
it'll go as a base hit for anderton
simmons
donaldson with a fly to center and a
ground ball to shore short
high fly deep center field hamilton
going back looking up
and it's gone off the facing of the
delta sky 360 suite in center field a
two-run home run for donaldson
his fifth of the year that ball was just
absolutely crushed winds are down 14-3
in the seventh inning two on one out and
here is a rise
swinging a miss it's a cutter fading
away two down
that's one of the better pitches of the
night because the rise doesn't strike
out very much
heikole to andrewton simmons swinging a
ground ball to third nice pick by
mendic he'll throw to madrigal at the
bag at seconds probably it for kykel as
he gets
through seven tonight the white sox
carry a 14-3 lead into the eighth
billy hamilton bases loaded no outs
billy hamilton into left field and this
will get
run number 15 home grandau heads to the
plate
and an extra base at third for laori
garcia
it is 15-3 as he pops her eyes on the
head
it's the white sox 15 twins four and
willian zastadil will pitch
for the third time in his career second
time this season and that got the crowd
pretty fired up
you've got five nine 225 up against five
eleven two forty five
looks like a softball slow pitch
softball game it's three and oh
he loaded up mercedes tattoos it to
center it is gone
there you go a 3-0 swing
and it's 16-4 well i'm thinking that
probably doesn't
and we go to the bottom of the night so
two away
and it's garlic and garrett find one
more missed bat
oh it's a slider hit well to left and
run down jake lamb has the final
out and the sox waltz into minnesota
nick madrigal it's his first home run
and a win
by a dozen the sox are 4-0 against the
twins this year's